All right, so Joe Biden did an event yesterday
where he spoke about Donald Trump's nomination
of Amy CONI Barrett to the Supreme Court to
replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
We already looked at clips from the nomination
ceremony on Saturday that Donald Trump held
at the White House.
And at this event, Joe Biden also took questions
from the media.
Now, as all of you know, I don't agree with
Joe Biden on every policy or nearly every
policy.
But in some places, I think Joe Biden has
put together some pretty reasonable platforms,
which I would love to see made a reality if
he becomes president.
But Joe Biden yesterday did something really
well, which is that he refused to play Donald
Trump's games and he refused to play some
of the games that the media gets Donald Trump
to play.
But Joe Biden wasn't going to go for it because
Joe Biden was asked in light of Trump's Supreme
Court nominee and the nomination being so
hypocritical, given that Republicans in 2016
said, oh, we don't confirm justices in the
last year of a term.
And now with 40 days to go, they want to confirm
a Supreme Court justice.
In light of that hypocrisy, a question that
has come up is whether Joe Biden will try
to pack the Supreme Court if he wins.
Should Democrats try to pack the Supreme Court
now packing?
The Supreme Court is essentially expanding
the court.
You add justices.
So if Donald Trump gets Amy CONI Barrett confirmed,
you would have a Supreme Court that leans
six to three in the direction of conservatives.
Joe Biden could add four seats to the Supreme
Court.
That would make it a 13 justice court instead
of nine.
And he could appoint left wing justices to
those four new seats, taking control of the
court back, making it a seven six Liberal
majority.
Now, of course, this is hugely controversial.
It's a major issue.
It is a nonstarter.
If Joe Biden doesn't win and it doesn't happen
in conjunction with Democrats taking the Senate.
But the great thing Joe Biden does is he realizes
that whether he says yes or no, it's trouble
and he's not going to play the game with the
reporter.
And he keeps the focus on the now.
Take a look at how Joe Biden handled this
piece.
Almost no, I have no comment.
This question Sanders is.
Well, having worked as a person under any
circumstances, I am not.
And I know you're going to be upset with my
answer, but what I'm not going to do is play
the Trump game, which is a good game he plays.
Take your eye off the issue before us.
If I were to say yes or no to that, that becomes
a big issue.
That's the headline here.
I am focused on one thing right now, and I
really mean it.
I'm focused on making sure the American people
understand that they're being cut out of this
process.
They're entitled to be part of the cut out
designed in order to take away the ACA and
your health care in the midst of a pandemic.
That's the focus.
That's what it's on.
And that's the deal.
Thank you also very, very much.
Thank you.
So tomorrow we're going to look at a clip
of Dr. Jill Biden handling a sort of bogus
direction during a CNN interview.
But Joe Biden doing the right thing here.
Joe Biden is correctly identifying that you
can't win with that question.
If Joe Biden says, yes, I will consider packing
the court or I will definitely try to pack
the court, the right goes crazy and calls
Biden an authoritarian and a fascist and all
the things that Donald Trump actually wants
to be.
If Joe Biden says, yes, I will pack the court.
Those on the left who think it's a bad idea,
that it's a divisive idea.
They will get mad at Joe Biden.
And then if Joe Biden says, no, I won't consider
packing the court.
Those on the left who want him to pack the
court will say this is why the Dems lose their
week.
They give then they won't ever do what they
need to do.
So Joe Biden correctly points out right now
Donald Trump is trying to get Amy CONI Barrett
confirmed.
She wants to get rid of the Affordable Care
Act.
She's very much against Roe v. Wade.
Period.
That's the issue right now.
And this is something that I guess we've become
kind of dissents or not these that we've we've
I am Reeth sensitized to when an elected official
properly handles a bad question or a poorly
framed question, because with the Trump administration,
it's either Trump's ask the question and he
just talks about something totally different.
Or Trump is asked a question and he lies.
But this is actually how you handle some of
these questions that have no possible upside.
Now, earlier in the event, Joe Biden also
made it very clear, and I think that this
goes to something that's astute that Biden
and his campaign are doing right now.
Joe Biden makes clear that what Donald Trump
is doing on the Supreme Court is outrageous
and that at the core of it is wanting to dismantle
a lot of this policy, including the Affordable
Care Act.
Take a look.
Surely before Justice Ginsburg's passed, she
she told her granddaughter, and I quote, My
most fervent wish is that I will not be replaced
until a new president is installed.
And the quote wasn't a personal request.
Wasn't a favor being asked for.
It was the last act of a long, unflinching
career of standing up for American democracy.
Never before in our nation's history as a
Supreme Court justice been nominated and installed
while a presidential election is already underway.
It defies every precedent, every expectation
of a nation where the people, the people are
sovereign and the rule of law reigns.
But yesterday, before Justice Ginsburg could
be laid to rest and after one hundred thousands
of Americans had already cast their ballots,
the president nominated a successor to her
seat.
It's no mystery about what's happening here.
President Trump was trying to throw out the
Affordable Care Act.
He's been trying to do it for the last four
years.
The Republican Party has been trying to eliminate
it for a decade.
So I don't agree with Biden all the time on
policy.
I certainly don't agree with Biden all the
time on strategy.
But I think that this is logical.
Keep the pressure on what they are trying
to do right now rather than the hypotheticals.
If Joe Biden wins, there's more than enough
time for those hypotheticals.
And when the hypotheticals might ingratiate
you with some but alienate others, there's
very little upside to going in that direction.
What Joe Biden is trying to do here is to
cement in the minds of the voters the stakes
that are at play and that hopefully I'm hoping
he will do that tomorrow night during the
first presidential debate tomorrow, Tuesday.
We will be starting live coverage of the first
presidential debate between Donald Trump and
Joseph R. Biden Jr. eight thirty p.m. Eastern
Time, five thirty p.m. Pacific.
We will be live on YouTube, live on Twitch
and live on Facebook.
I hope you will join me.
This is precisely the correct messaging from
Joe Biden.
And by the way, as of now, we're getting into
just real nitty gritty policy.
I still don't understand how repealing or
gutting the Affordable Care Act without a
real replacement plan, which Trump doesn't
have days before an election.
I don't even get how that's a winning strategy
for Donald Trump.
That's another story altogether.
But they are again talking about how quickly
can we get rid of the Affordable Care Act
days before an election with no plan to replace
it.
You're going to try to get rid of it.
I don't see how that's winning electoral strategy.
But Donald Trump did win in 2016, so maybe
he knows something I don't.